all right got a couple videos up game
news for you everyone loves games we're
gonna start out with the 3ds now I
personally have not picked up my 3ds yet
I was all set to do it I was like all
right I'm gonna go there drop 250 bucks
and fifty dollars on a game and then I
looked at the launch titles and I was
like why would I do that and that's
pretty much my main gripe and the point
of this video now I have played the 3ds
and I'll tell you it's actually a really
cool piece of tech I thought the 3d
would look like those really crappy 3d
postcards they're made in the 90s but
they don't the 3ds actually really legit
it's not 2d images on 3d backgrounds or
anything like that it's all 3d no
glasses either and that's always good
now it's pretty specific in the way you
hold up and you can't like tilt it that
way that way you have to be right there
and you're like alright that's perfect
don't move an inch and you can adjust
the depth of the 3d so if it's hurting
your eyes try to adjust that it's
probably just too deep I meant too deep
at the shutup and if you don't like 3d
can't turn the 3d off so ultimately you
have just a more powerful DS but it is
more powerful but what is it with
systems having really horribly weak
launch titles the best two are Street
Fighter 4 which I have two copies as
Street Fighter 4 in my house right now
and pilot wings which kind of got my
reviews it's pilot wings good have you
played it
comment below let me know about that
because I've heard it's not that great
and the Super Nintendo in nintendo 64
versions of pilot wings were awesome so
it's kind of sad you know the first
pilot wings in 15 years not being that
great and was really depressing about
this is Nintendo's usually the good one
it's not like they packed their games
with sewer shark or King Kong the movie
if you look back the launch game for
Super Nintendo with Super Mario World in
tender 64 had the definitive 3d
platformer Super Mario 64 though we had
some crap titles but it also had Legend
of Zelda Twilight Princess that is how
you launch a system right there and now
we have a slew of really mediocre launch
titles for the 3ds because I'm pretty
sure they're thinking those 3d games
people are gonna buy them to see the 3d
so it doesn't matter and that's really
annoying especially since a couple
months from now they're gonna have Star
Fox for the 3ds Legend of Zelda Ocarina
of Time Kid Icarus and if you've ever
wondered if it's pronounced Kid Icarus
or Kid Icarus its Icarus Icarus thus
sayeth the dictionary and now you know
which yeah two of those games are just
pours but in 3d but those three games
would have made the 3ds have a really
solid launch but instead mediocracy and
I guess the 3ds is gonna have like a
Virtual Console for portable games which
is like what the Wii has and that would
be really cool if that launched the day
of the 3ds also know it's coming out
later so ultimately you're gonna have a
new 3d system that's gonna be really
cool
with games that are if you don't have
street fight
already I'd say that's the game to get
but I mean like I said I do so have you
picked up your 3ds yet I'm gonna pick
mine up in June when everything good
comes out and what do you think of it
what are the features that you like and
what do you think of the game you got
with it is it good comment below let me
know and if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more